the first hire should free you up to do
more Revenue generating activities it's
less about how much they're going to
make you but more about how much time
they can take off your plate so that you
can fill your plate up so let's say you
can do five thousand dollars a month on
your own but eighty percent of your time
is spent doing administrative tasks okay
well if you get somebody to take the 80
off then the 20 that's Revenue
generating can then become a hundred
percent and then you can 5x your income
to go to twenty five thousand dollars a
month and you can be able to cover the
cost of the other person so the concept
in entrepreneurship of hiring is always
just trading up your time in terms of
value per unit of second that you can
generate as an entrepreneur